is deep sea diving one of the fastest
ways to make money in animal crossing
new horizons
we'll put it to the test in today's
video people of the internet retro
recontour here and welcome back to
another animal crossing new horizons
video
if we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube now in one of my most popular
videos today we talk about
five ways to make money in animal
crossing new horizons that doesn't
involve turnips and on the comments
section of that video one of the things
that you guys
kept suggesting over and over and over
again was that i needed to go
deep sea diving now when i made that
original video deep sea fishing hadn't
been
out for all that long so i didn't really
have a chance to test it
guess what that's what we're gonna do in
today's video guys and we're starting
right now all right so i'm gonna speed
up some of this so you guys don't have
to sit and watch me do every single
thing but i also want to make this
really what it would be like for you or
anyone out there who may decide hey
i want to go deep sea diving and i want
to maximize the amount of time spent so
you can see it's about 8
22 p.m right now on my island so we're
gonna test
everything how long it takes what all
you need to do to get ready
and then we're gonna actually go into
nooks cranny hopefully if we get done in
time before 10 pm
and then sell the items to see what we
get now of course you guys know
certain creatures come out at certain
times of the day so you could
maximize your time by trying to only
deep sea dive whenever there's going to
be
high value creatures out there but just
for this video we're just going to be
going at the time i have available right
now which is 8 23 p.m in the evening
so the first thing we'll need to do is
we'll need to put on our wetsuit so i
have that on
underneath so i'm just going to go ahead
and remove this with my wand here so now
i'm in my wetsuit
and the next thing that you would need
to do is you would need to remove
all of the items from your inventory
here so if we want to maximize our time
guys we want to make sure that we don't
have anything and i mean
anything here in our inventory so i'm
going to go ahead and head down to the
beach
and then we will dump all of our items
there now don't
mind my island right now guys parts of
it are
looking great other parts of it i am
just really been neglecting it like see
this flower right here driving me crazy
really do not need it there
so just ignore some of those spots and
focus on the more completed areas
so we are here at the beach you know
what i love diving off the beer so let's
head over here to the pier
now as i mentioned though we need to
remove all of our items so i'm gonna do
that first i'm just gonna drop them on
the beach here
so just go through one by one all right
so that's it we've removed
everything from our inventory and you
can see that we have indeed unlocked all
four rows here if you're newer at the
game and you don't have all of these
unlocked yet don't worry that will all
come in due
time but i have 40 total inventory slots
here so we're gonna see exactly how long
it will take
all right and with that we are ready to
dive into the ocean
and go deep sea diving all right guys
here we go we've got one
right over here this is gonna be our
first catch remember we have to catch
a total of 40 right here now when it
comes to
making money in an animal crossing new
horizons a huge part of it honestly is
about
a how much time you have to spend doing
the task
and then b how enjoyable that task
is now for me personally my thoughts
going into this when you guys kept
suggesting it and you can see here we
got pascal on our first attempt here
hey man about the scallop of yours can i
have it well okay fine we'll let you
have this one might as well go ahead and
all good you take it i'll get something
cool back in return
but as i was saying it's really a
balance of a how long it takes to do the
activity and then b
how enjoyable it is
oh we've got a fast one here guys
actually he's not really fast but he is
trying to evade
he is trying to evade ours here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna creep up on
him
nice and slow nice and slow here we're
gonna creep up on him
just gonna get right above him right
here and then we're gonna go
down let's see did we time it just right
yes we did
and we got a snow crab all right let's
go
[Music]
all right guys looks like we got a
runner here
not too bad though not too bad we got
him and what do we have a mantis
shrimp shrimply amazing
[Music]
so
okay guys we have swam all the way
around my island it's been
roughly 20 minutes so far let's take a
look at my inventory and see where we
currently stand
wow okay we are a lot further on than i
expected to be
we only have six slots remaining guys we
are getting pretty close to the end here
what we'll do
after we catch these next six is we'll
go through and we'll organize all these
i'll tell you exactly
how many i got of each one and then
we'll go and sell them at nook's cranny
let's go ahead and dive back into the
water
[Music]
all right guys it's only fitting that
near the end we would run into
one that actually presents a little bit
of a problem for us and finally
we're able to get him there a snow crab
it's giving me the cold shoulder
and we have one more to go here i think
there was one just right over here let's
head on over and see if we can wrap this
up
oh yeah this one's not gonna get away
from us at all right there
first try we got him what do we have and
another
acorn barnacle okay guys so initial
reaction uh let's check the timer right
there it is 8
46 wow so we'll get the exact time when
i go back and edit the video but just
right now i think that was about 23
minutes 25 minutes somewhere in that
range
so initial reaction this did not take
nearly
as long as i expected i i was expecting
it to take
at least half an hour if not 45 minutes
or more
to collect all 40 slots with
deep sea creatures now you can probably
see even though the video was sped up
you could probably see that none of them
really posed too big of a problem for me
i didn't really have any that were super
fast trying to get away
so it wasn't too bad overall but let's
go ahead and head back ashore and
see what we got okay guys here is the
complete inventory
all 40 slots filled up here and you can
see the breakdown here we had eight
seaweed
two scallops then we've got four sea
cucumbers
two mantis shrimp four turbine shells
three welks four acorn barnacles
three sea slugs two dungeness crabs
two snow crabs two pearl oysters
two sea stars one octopus and one
pearl now as i said in the beginning i
did not
target a specific time i wasn't
targeting a specific deep sea creature
this was just going to be an example of
someone out there who decided hey you
know what i've got an extra half an hour
to an hour
tonight i just want to go around deep
sea diving and see
how much money i can make so i'm sure if
you went at a certain time of day and
targeted specific creatures you could
make
even more but it would also probably
take you a lot more time
as well so we're gonna go ahead and head
inside of nook's cranny here and see
how much we get for all of this stuff
all right guys the moment of truth here
how many bells do we
earn for spending roughly half an hour
to fill our inventory completely full
of deep sea creatures we're gonna go
through we're gonna sell
every single item here none of these are
new
i've caught all these before don't have
anything to donate
to the museum i'm honestly curious like
i
i really want to see what all this is
worth here guys so let's go ahead and
hit confirm there
59 000 bells guys there you have it so
actually more than about a thousand
bells per minute almost
2 000 bells per minute if i am doing
that quick math right there i think
that's pretty close
so honestly not bad sold i'll definitely
take those bells
okay guys retro from the future here
i've now had a chance to go back and
watch the video
we started at 8 23 p.m and keep in mind
that was before we even put on the
wetsuit and removed all of the items
from our inventory so
from that exact moment to when we caught
the final
40th item right there it would be
exactly
23 minutes so if you go ahead and you
take away the time that it took me to
put on my wetsuit and to discard all my
items
really you're looking at actually about
20 minutes of
deep sea diving if you want to go ahead
and round up everything by the time you
sell and by the time you
get rid of all your items and things
like that then maybe you want to round
up to half an hour but
20 to 30 minutes i think for 59 000
bells
is really pretty solid now i did get
lucky there i got pascal
who gave me a pearl which the pearl
alone is worth
ten thousand so that was certainly a
nice chunk but other than that i don't
think i really caught anything
super rare there was a lot of seaweed in
there so i
have to agree with you guys everyone who
suggested that in the comments
this is a really relaxing easy way to
spend
20 30 minutes and get about 59 000 bells
to be completely fair though i have to
say this is not something that i would
want to do for an extended amount of
time it can get very boring
pretty fast but again for a session a
night or a session a week
it's really not too bad now if you
decide to try this yourself when you
finish up you can either go back and do
it again
or make sure you don't forget to go back
to the beach and pick up
all your inventory maybe you left it in
your house instead that would probably
be the smarter thing to do
but i left all mine on the beach here so
i'm gonna go back and pick everything up
notice i will have a slot filled now
because my
total number of bells went over a
hundred thousand so that's why i have 99
000 bells here now but i'm just gonna go
through and pick everything back up
guys let me know how many bells you've
gotten in a single haul
of deep sea creatures and let me know
what other things you like to do
to make money in animal crossing new
horizons as always folks thank you all
so much for watching
and i'll talk to you again soon